Harold joined me in an extremely
informal process he had been a
postdoctoral fellow at National
Institutes of Health and had taken a
course in tumor viruses he was he was
working at the time with phage and
bacterium and I remember his showing up
at my little office which I shared with
a postdoc and every time I wanted to get
to my desk the postdoc have to get up
and walk out of the office so I did
did any of it explain what he was up to
and I think about five minutes in the
conversation I decided we got this guy
in a lab because he was obviously very
smart and we were on the same wavelength
scientifically we wanted to do molecular
biology on the virus and we shared other
interests cultural interests
particularly literary interests Harold
was more accomplished in that area and I
am because he was he was not a science
major in college he was Leroy major had
a master's degree from Harvard in
English literature in that way too we
were the same similar if you will we we
both entered sciences more or less naive
a little less naive about science per se
because I take chemistry courses physics
courses what-have-you and to a greater
extent and with greater enthusiasm that
Harold had in college but as far as
research laboratory experience is
concerned we were both naive and were
bootstrapping ourselves into careers as
research scientists so we were
personally
simpatico intellectually simpatico and I
signed him up immediately it took six
months maybe no more than a year before
Harold had established himself in lab
with such authority
that we since we formed a partnership in
which we began to co-mentor most of the
graduate students and postdocs and which
was a rapidly growing lab one
distinction I which I think has been
over dramatized
but which I may be responsible for
originally is that Harold was a stickler
for detail and in our discussions with
postdocs of students he would
relentlessly press them on this detail
that detail lack control of this control
and I was a bit more of a generalist I I
would let people run a little bit before
raining them calling into calling them
on deficiency what they're doing so I we
became distinguished by Harold was the
detail guy and I was the generalist
and that's really kind of silly I mean I
never ever neglected detail and Harold
was this profound the generalist as any
I've ever known other than that I think
we were two birds of a feather
you